does your name have to be unique I'm
going to answer that question in today's
episode of ask Evan so obviously put out
a video on my channel that was for my
tgim mastermind group I have a new group
that we meet on Mondays and people share
their resources and share their problems
and I help them out and it's a great way
to start off your week right to have a
monday morning start a few week on a
high to help your business grow and i
posted a video on it and i got a comment
in there and somebody said you know eric
thomas hip hop preacher already has a
tgim series and this kind of thinking
drives me nuts so what so what if
somebody else already has the same thing
with the same name what he does is
different than what I do right he has a
video series that comes out every monday
and i love it and it's great and i watch
and I love comments on some of them what
up what up what up what up water that's
right it's your boy ec and welcome to
another edition of bring it from the
bottom thank God is mine
hey whoa mine is different right I'm
putting my stamp on it mine is a
mastermind group and you know unless
somebody has patented the name or
trademarked and copyrighted the name
then if it's not protected what's to
prevent somebody from going out and
using it and put in your own stamp on it
you know I use belief right believe has
been used as song titles it's been used
as movies as be used in TV shows Britney
Spears has a fragrance line called
believe SeaWorld has a has a Shamu show
called believe you know halo 3 had a
marketing campaign called bleep so
because all of these companies and
people have used believed before does
that mean that I can't use it that mean
that Britney Spears owns believe and I'm
not allowed to name something after it
and this confession is killing me
don't you know I still believe that you
will be here and give me a sign hit me
baby one more time there's other people
named Evan does that mean I can't have
my name be Evan there's other Evan
Carmichael is that ever Carmichael who's
a wrestler out there does that mean I
need to change my name or he needs to
change his name it's ridiculous just
because somebody else has used the name
unless it's protected you can go ahead
and use it to and put your stamp on it
and stop focusing what other people are
thinking and other people's judgments
and instead put your own mark on it and
make it awesome and this kind of
thinking just kind of drives me nuts you
know you're watching these videos to get
inspiration ideas to help you grow your
business and and hopefully they're on a
positive note and hopefully you're
getting inspired by them and sometimes
when I get comments like that just kind
of drives me nuts so what if somebody
else already has a TGI em series I'm
making my own mine is awesome too I love
it it's providing value the people in
the group are are seeing growth in their
business and at the end of day that's
all that matters holy a question today
for you guys is should I change my name
from TGIM I want to know your thoughts
leave it in the comments below I could
actually be Britney Spears what up what
up what up what up what up what up
that's right it's your boy ec and
welcome to another edition knows what I
say what does he say what up what up
what up what up water that's right okay
that's right it's your boy you see okay